Поляку Міхалу лише 21. Він приїхав до Львова з Любліна. Чекає, що скажуть у військкоматі: як іноземцеві долучитися до української армії.
Моя мама і її предки з України. Мама померла, коли мені було 8 років.
Зараз частина моєї родини в Нововолинську, це західна Україна. А я все життя прожив у Польщі.
Коли почалася війна, я перш за все вивіз батьків своєї дівчини у безпечне місце, вони приїхали зі Львова.
А я тепер маю зробити все можливе, щоб боротися з російською агресією.
Про те, що хлопець поїхав в Україну, не знають ані його родина, ані друзі. Але він не відмовляється від інтерв'ю.
Хоче підтримати українців і показати приклад європейцям.
Зараз, на мою думку, війна - це загроза не лише для України, а й для всієї Європи.
Чоловікам у Європі зараз варто припинити говорити, що це не їхня проблема.
А радше намагатися захистити українських жінок і дітей.
Поки ми спілкуємося з Міхалом, до військкомату підходять хлопці з Великобританії, Нідерландів, США.
Вони не хочуть показувати обличчя. Але так само приїхали на війну.
Разом з ними - француз Поль. Йому 23, він студент, не має жодного військового досвіду.
Можливо, коли в мене вперше стрілятимуть, я накладу собі в штани. Не знаю, як воно буде.
Але зараз я готовий воювати і боротися.
Моя країна не задіяна. Але ми не знаємо, що буде в майбутньому.
Я відчуваю єдність з українцями, тому що Україна - європейська країна. Мене турбує, що в ній точиться війна, і я вирішив допомогти.
На момент виходу цього сюжету Міхал і Поль вступили до лав міжнародного легіону тероборони.
Вони підписали контракт, отримали спорядження, проходять тренування. Для інших добровольців з-за кордону вже з'явився сайт з інструкціями.
Радять звертатися до українських посольств за кордоном. Візи - скасовані. В Україні на цих бійців чекають.
Україна вже зустрічає іноземних добровольців, які їдуть у нашу державу. Перші з шістнадцяти тисяч.
Вони їдуть захищати свободу. Захищати життя. Для нас. Для всіх. І це буде успішно. Я в цьому впевнений.
Дмитро - громадянин Узбекистану, але останні 20 років жив у Німеччині, працював механіком.
Він не вперше приїздить в Україну. Його мати - родом з Харкова. У Києві багато друзів.
До них він і сподівається доїхати - у складі міжнародного легіону територіальної оборони.
Приїхав добровільно, за власним бажанням. Тому що вже два тижні не можу ані їсти, ані пити, ані спати.
Всі ці жахи бачу по телебаченню, ніяк не можу собі місця знайти. В один день вирішив, взяв квиток, зібрав речі, звільнився з роботи.
Чоловік говорить російською, англійською, французькою і німецькою, українську розуміє. Служив в армії.
Як вихідець із пострадянської країни каже, що хоче боротися з імперськими амбіціями російського президента.
Зло не може перемогти. Неможливо проти народу ось так піти, так народ покарати.
Це велика помилка цього злочинця - скажу на камеру - Володимира Путіна… путлера!
Іноземні добровольці, з якими ми поспілкувалися, не мають сумнівів, що чинять правильно й роблять добру справу.
Коли я побачив, що Росія напала на Україну, мене це вразило. Я одразу подумав, що маю допомогти українцям.
Я повторюватиму знову й знову: поляки воюватимуть не просто за Україну, а за весь український народ.
Усе буде добре, я думаю, до літа все буде нормально. Україна буде вільною країною, відродиться знову, відбудуємо Україну. Усе буде чудово.
Кілька десятків бійців із Грузії вже прибули в Україну.
До українського посольства у США звернулися три тисячі американських добровольців. До бельгійської амбасади - близько сотні європейців.
За даними МЗС України, з 52 країн надійшло близько 20 тисяч заявок.
В українських соцмережах тим часом жартують, мовляв, скоро НАТО захоче вступити до Збройних сил України.
Поки не весь Альянс, але чимало військових з країн-членів таку ідею вже втілюють у життя.